we tend to think of laws as restrictions
things that you can't do
or things that you're forced to do
against your will clean up your room
stand up straight pick up your feet
take it like a man be nice to your
sister don't mix beer and wine ever
and oh yeah don't drive on the railroad
track
phil that's one i happen to agree with
but did you know that sometimes the law
can actually lift these restrictions and
give you freedoms to
do things you wouldn't otherwise be able
to do yes sometimes the law can give you
rights that you don't even know about
not that you'd necessarily want to use
some of these rights
but still let's talk about some of those
rights that you didn't know you had
[Music]
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
now warning
restrictions may apply please see your
doctor before attempting any of these
freedoms and more importantly please
consult
with your attorney so let's kick things
off with a woman's right to go
topless in 2015 the fort collins city
council enacted a public nudity
ordinance banning women from removing
their shirts in public i'm not going to
read the whole
statute you can do that yourselves but
obviously the law bans women from doing
something men are legally allowed to do
a woman's group sued the city arguing
that a female only topless band
violated the equal protection clause how
did the city defend the ban well for
starters it argued that men and women's
chests were totally different
which also means women quote have a
hallowed sexual status in western
culture the city tried hard to make it
sound as if this reasoning was based on
something other than the stereotypes
but this did not go over particularly
well for a gender-based classification
to survive a legal challenge
the government needs to show quote an
exceedingly persuasive justification
that the
classification is necessary that
classification must serve
an important governmental objective
through means quote substantially
related to
achieving those objectives what
objectives did the ban
serve well fort collins said it served
two main purposes
first the city's ban would protect
children from seeing a female breast
because obviously that's not the
defining characteristic of a mammal and
mammalian children
never see a female pressed in their
entire lives and second it would prevent
general lawlessness especially traffic
problems that may occur
when people see a topless woman in
public ah yes
men can't control themselves so let's
limit what women can do
the court made quick work of the city's
reasoning although other courts have
decided this differently the 10th
circuit thought this was bunk and that
women's rights were being violated fort
collins spent 300 000
on this case and decided to throw in the
towel rather than appealing it to the
supreme court so if you live in utah
colorado wyoming new mexico kansas and
oklahoma you can take your shirt off
outside
no matter who you are the right to get
married by proxy most people are
familiar with the process for getting
hitched get a marriage license have a
ceremony
file the completed license with a state
discover irreconcilable differences
hire a lawyer exactly revenge wish you
were dead get divorced
and repeat but did you know it's
possible to get married without showing
up for the wedding
itself well if you're overseas in the
military or just have something better
to do that day
someone else can actually stand in for
you in many different states this is
known as a proxy marriage because
someone stands in for the other party to
take the vows to do this you need to
authorize your agent to get married on
your behalf now most states allow a
proxy marriage where one person can't be
present
but in montana a wedding can take place
without either party being present this
is what's called a
double proxy marriage now to qualify for
a double proxy wedding in montana
at least one party must be on active
duty in the military or a resident of
montana at the time of the application
for the license
why would someone want to do this you
ask other than the obvious reason that
you actually love this person
well cold hard cash obviously for
service members marriage can be a great
financial arrangement the army will
actually increase your pay by at least
twelve hundred dollars a month once
you're married now the montana marriage
law was first passed to the 1860s when
men
poured into the area to work in the
mines the miners didn't have the time or
the money to travel home to get their
fiances so
the state passed a law allowing
ceremonies to take place without either
person being present proxy marriage
isn't just for the military though
some states allow prisoners to get
married through a proxy in
1987 the supreme court case known as
turner versus saffly
granted prisoners the constitutional
right to marry however the right to
marry is also subject to reasonable
prison regulations
as long as the regulations are quote
reasonably related to legitimate
penalogical interests get your mind
out of the gutter ah come on we're all
just trying to have a good time
this means prisons can do all sorts of
things to delay or prevent marriages
in 2013 texas simply outlawed proxy
marriages including for inmates
their main concern was that people were
burying just to convey benefits
and that kind of fraudulent arrangement
was featured on the popular reality show
love after lock-up where
a doofus named vince was going to marry
ex-inmate amber
and adopt her girlfriend puppy as some
sort of insurance
and pension scheme i'm a bold mother
though three years later the state
reversed itself after advocates pointed
out that the law was in direct conflict
with turner versus saffly
the right to an annulment if you get
married on a dare so you have the right
to get married without being present at
the ceremony
fantastic but what if your best friend
double dog dares you to get married to
that hose beast over there and like
marty mcfly you follow through on the
dare then you sober up look at your
bride or groom next to you and say oh no
i got married because someone dared me
to
you know that old chestnut
got it a week after we started dating
well relax because if you live in
delaware or colorado
getting married on a dare is grounds for
an annulment and unlike divorce an
annulment treats the marriage as if it
never
existed annulments are usually only
available if there was fraud or coercion
or illegality at the time of the
marriage but delaware and colorado
include a
got married as a sort of joke as a
ground for annulment
the relevant law in delaware is 13
delaware code section 1506
which includes this as a justification
for annulment one or both parties
entered into the marriage as a jest or
dare now of course the state requires
some proof of the jest order and the
petition for divorce or annulment form
asks you to describe how and when you
learned of the jest or dare so if you
are married for decades with several
children
don't expect the court to just rubber
stamp your claim that
you got married on a dare and it should
be nullified
the right to get away with murder in
yellowstone national park now
speaking of marriage let's talk about
murder have you
have you ever fantasized about
committing the perfect crime well
michigan state law professor brian cult
certainly has he wrote a law review
article explaining how you could get
away with murder
in yellowstone national park cult
grounds his argument in the plain
meaning of the constitution
although yellowstone is mostly located
in wyoming about nine percent of the
park is actually located in montana
and an even smaller portion about 50
square miles is located in idaho
yellowstone was established in 1872
long before these states were added to
the union and when the states were
admitted each seated over exclusive
jurisdiction of its portion of
yellowstone to the federal government
and both article 1 section 8 and federal
law
give the federal government exclusive
jurisdiction over yellowstone national
park
and state law doesn't apply there later
when congress created the federal
district court for wyoming it placed the
entire park under that jurisdiction
that means that things that happen in
montana and idaho on park lands
are within the wyoming district court's
jurisdiction however article 3 section 2
of the constitution requires that the
trial be held in the state in which the
crime was committed
this sets up the legal basis for getting
away with murder if you commit a crime
in yellowstone national park
in idaho and moreover the sixth
amendment requires the impartial jury of
the state and district wherein the crime
shall have been committed
so theoretically the only people
available for the jury must live in the
idaho section of
yellowstone national park the thing is
no one lives on the 50 square miles of
federal land that make up this zone in
idaho so you can see how small that zone
is on the map and since no humans live
there only these idaho otters can judge
you and this
is why that area has been nicknamed the
zone of death the wyoming federal court
has jurisdiction but if you want to go
to trial
the wyoming court simply doesn't have
jurisdiction and although
cult tried to get congress to fix this
loophole they haven't done anything
shocker and that loophole still exists
so if you want to visit the idaho
portion of yellowstone national park
idaho is just dying to meet you
[Music]
the right to run for governor of kansas
as a teen dog or resident of another
state
in kansas almost anyone can be governor
in kansas you can run for governor
before you're even eligible to vote the
state has absolutely no qualifications
for governatorial candidates
in 2018 seven teenagers all boys ran for
kansas governor
the director of elections at the kansas
secretary of state's office said
there's seriously nothing on the books
that lays out anything no age no
residency no experience
nothing this was confirmed by
ballotpedia the website which tracks
all things related to state and federal
offices ballotpedia concludes that
kansas's constitution does not set out
requirements for office
cool that means that even a baby could
run for governor someone alert al
baldwin about a possible extension of
the boss baby cinematic universe
i may look like a baby but i was born
all grown up
this is amazing for many reasons
including the fact that former kansas
secretary of state kris kobach
has spent the last five years stoking
fears about mass voter fraud and
championing extremely restrictive voter
id laws
if it's not on the list it doesn't exist
in fact kobach briefly ran president
trump's election commission which was
supposed to prove that president trump
actually won the popular vote in 2016.
the commission disbanded after it found
no evidence of voter fraud
kobach wanted it to be harder to vote
and he proposed a federal law requiring
people to have proof of american
citizenship
when they showed up at the polls but
during his time as secretary of state he
never made any recommendations about the
state's non-existent requirements to run
for governor kansas legislators
immediately started discussing ways to
clarify the law but nothing stopped the
election with the teens from moving
forward
and there's also no residency
requirements so candidates from vermont
and new york threw their hats into the
ring as well it's not even clear that a
person has to be human to qualify for
kansas governor the director of
elections said that although no dog has
ever attempted to run there's no law
specifically stating that a candidate
has to be human so
stella the legal beagle will be filing
her paperwork for 2022
the right to write on u.s currency
speaking of good or
bad government let's talk about the us
treasury specifically
money have you ever felt like riding on
money but worried about that pesky thing
called a felony well don't fret because
you've got a right to deface
u.s currency the common belief that you
can't ride on or market bills is
actually a misinterpretation of united
states code title 18 part 1 chapter 17
section 333 which states
whoever mutilates cuts to faces
disfigures or perforates or unites or
cements together or does any other thing
to any bank bill draft note or other
evidence of debt issued by any national
banking association or federal reserve
bank or the federal reserve system with
intent to render such bank bill draft
note or other evidence of debt
unfit to be reissued shall be fined
under this title or imprisoned by not
more than six months or both
i did it this crime boils down to intent
did you
intend to render the bill unfit to be
reissued if not then no harm no foul
it's not as if every time a bill has
markings on it it's removed from
circulation so
feel free to draw a beard on alexander
hamilton it may be dumb but you can
still spend that hundred dollar dollar
bill y'all
when is a bill unfit if it's torn dirty
limp worn or
defaced according to the federal reserve
a bill is unfit if it has excessive
holes tears tape or excessive graffiti
so a black eye on george washington is
probably okay but a torn and half bill
is probably not
not that there's any reason why you
should be tearing up your own money
money is better when you can spend it
not legal advice common sense
the right to give your children alcohol
philosopher william smith famously
observed that
parents just don't understand but just
because carlton and viv and uncle phil
were square doesn't mean that all
parents are narcs massachusetts parents
will absolutely fight for your right to
party
chug chug it chug it drop it target
that's why the legal drinking age in
massachusetts is 21 and it's illegal to
provide alcohol to minors
unless they are your children or
grandchildren please excuse my parents
behavior they ate a lot of paint chips
growing up
the commonwealth's social host law makes
it illegal to buy alcohol or host
parties where underage people drink
however there is an exception for the
host children and grandchildren who
maybe served booze on the host's private
property and there's no age limit here
so if you want to give your
toddler scotch knock yourself out again
don't actually do that
hashtag not legal advice but this isn't
quite as crazy as it sounds on its face
some experts who advise state
legislators on responsible drinking
say that prohibition just doesn't work
and kids need to learn the right habits
from their parents
drinking alcohol with parents quote may
help teach them responsible drinking
habits or extinguish some of the novelty
or excitement of drinking
that's according to dr christie
longfoley at the school of medicine at
wake forest university and massachusetts
is far from alone in permitting parents
to make this decision
other states let underage people drink
too like alaska california colorado
delaware hawaii illinois
iowa louisiana maine maryland
mississippi missouri montana new
hampshire
nevada new jersey new mexico new york
ohio oregon pennsylvania rhode island
south dakota texas
virginia washington and wyoming plus in
some places people can get married
before the legal drinking age so
12 states say that you can drink with
your spouse if you are under the age of
21. but when it comes to drinking
there's something special about
massachusetts
it is not surprisingly illegal to give
someone alcohol or drugs if they're in a
hospital suffering from an alcohol or
drug-related problem
unless the physician says it's okay
because in boston doctors know that the
best cure for a hangover
is the hair of the dog that bit you i
know there's a red sox joke in there
somewhere
but since i'm not john krasinski despite
what you read in the comments i can
confirm that the red sox are
the worst just the worst but you have
the right to love them
and the right to be wrong but if you're
a rational person who enjoys exercising
their head as well as their freedoms
i explain one more extremely timely
right you didn't know you had over on
nebula if you create a website or a
platform
or both you still maintain the right to
kick people out if you don't agree with
what they're saying
i posted a whole extended version of
this video in fact almost all of my
videos have an ad-free extended version
on nebula and now you can get a huge
discount because sometimes even legal
issues are too hot for youtube because
youtube's algorithm can be quite
capricious which is why my creator
friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad free and also
experiment with original content and new
series
that probably wouldn't work on youtube
and not only are my nebula versions ad
free and extended but they're also
released early before the youtube
version nebula features lots of
youtube's top
educational-ish creators like extra
credits renee ritchie and mary spender
and we also get to collaborate in ways
that probably wouldn't work on youtube
and put out amazing original content
like
half as interesting's courtroom drama
where i play a fictional lawyer
alex nichols show alex goes bananas
where i play a real life lawyer
and lindsey ellis's documentary about
blazing saddles in which i took
no part so what does this all have to do
with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet they love
educational content and educational
creators and we worked out a deal where
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
the link in the description
you'll also get a nebulous subscription
for free and to be clear
that subscription is not a trial it's
free for as long as you're a curiosity
stream member and for a few more days
curiosity stream is offering a whopping
41
off of their annual plans that's less
than 12 per year
for both curiosity stream and nebula and
after that you'll get 26
off which is still a smoking hot deal
for both curiosity stream and nebula so
click on the link in the description to
get both curiosity stream and nebula for
a huge discount or you can go to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly
so just click on the link in the
description or go to curiositystream.com
legal eagle plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist with all my other
real lawyer reacts and all of my other
interesting videos about the law
i don't know click on this playlist and
i'll see you in court